moving on
our main story tonight concerns live
entertainment it's one of the things
that people missed the most during the
pandemic and everyone was very excited
to see it start to come back
it's been more than a year without them
but now the hampton coliseum is bringing
back concerts i'm pumped i'm ready to go
i'm vaccinated i'm ready to go i've been
locked up for a year 10 months and i'm
going to let loose and destroy this
place
you know what
let him have that everyone missed their
comfort zone with a pandemic for
instance i can guarantee that the
sentence i've been locked up for a year
and ten months and now i'm here to
destroy this place was also said several
times at the reopening of an ann taylor
loft everyone's been a bit edgy live
entertainment undeniably offers unique
experiences from taylor swift unveiling
her squad to a hologram 2-pack
performing at coachella to this
unsurpassed moment from a justin bieber
concert
[Applause]
good good i'm glad that happened
and while it is amazing to watch that
together now just imagine being there to
see it live in person
but if you've bought or even tried to
buy tickets recently you know those
experiences come at a cost
i just spent the last hour and 15
minutes trying to get pink tickets if
you don't want to be behind the stage
you're looking at 500
per ticket
who can afford that for the amount that
i'm paying to see any random ban that's
going on tour they better be [ __ ]
serenading me why are bad bunny tickets
so dammit
you're making me want to sell my
husband's feet on only fans
wow
that is a striking sentiment there
actually hold on hold on
for sale husband feet only fans yes we
did it we created a whole story in just
five words suck it hemingway suck it
now if you think tickets have been
getting ridiculously expensive they have
the average price for a popular content
has more than tripled since the mid-90s
vastly outpacing inflation and that is
before they hit the resale market and
with huge artists starting to put
tickets on sale for summer shows that
irritation is only likely to increase so
tonight we thought we'd try and explain
exactly why bad bunny tickets are so
expensive who is making money off them
and what you might be able to do about
it that does not involve selling your
husband's feet
and let's start with the company that
you're probably immediately thinking of
ticketmaster they are the biggest player
in the ticket market by far and claim
they strive to put fans first and that
the people we care most about are the
fans and yet as anyone who has ever
bought a ticket from them knows that's
generally not the feeling you get when
dealing with them as this youtuber
explains
if there was anything that i had as a
wish for any big artist or band that
comes through
whether it's kpop whether it's a western
artist i don't give a [ __ ] if you're a
magician any big ticket person that ever
comes through and does a concert never
use ticketmaster use literally anyone
else they are terrible
okay first excellent shade thrown at
magicians there it was noted and it was
appreciated but they're absolutely right
ticketmaster is one of the most hated
companies on earth which is really
impressive because remember this is a
planet in which at t also exists hey
guys we've still got a few weeks until
the merger goes through and i gotta say
it's gonna be a bumpy ride until then
and also after and look it is no secret
ticketmaster is horrible but exactly how
it is horrible is genuinely interesting
let's start with one of the things that
infuriates people the most about them
and that's the fees they can come as a
nasty surprise at the very end of a
transaction and can raise from the
annoying to the completely bat [ __ ] we
found a ticket to a 2019 kids pop
concert with fees that amounted to 75
percent of face value for one ticket to
a time in the creator show next week the
fees had an extra 78
and the fees on a 15 ticket to a monster
truck rally in houston was 16.41
that's more than the cost of the ticket
itself which is clearly ridiculous
although i will say in the case of that
kids bop tour it may actually have been
worth it because they could have played
this
i just took a dna test turns out i'm 100
that kid even when i'm crying crazy yeah
i got some problems that's the human in
me bling
stop it stop it right now and forever i
have so many issues with what you just
saw there the least of which is what
they did to the lyrics because if you
are saying took a dna test turns out i'm
100 that kid you were either a selling a
paternity dispute on maury or be
returning to your hometown after having
been kidnapped 30 years ago i swear guys
i just took a dna test turns out i'm 100
that kid
and while it is both easy and fun to
[ __ ] on ticketmaster for their fees as
they point out they're not solely
responsible for them instead they say
ticket fees are determined in
collaboration with our clients who share
in a portion of the fees we collect
which is true ticketmaster enters into
contracts that set and share fees with
the venues where concerts are held the
promoters who book market and organize
the shows and sometimes even the artists
themselves you could say ticketmaster's
business model is to stand in as the bad
guy and let all those other players hide
behind them or you could not say that
and just let ticketmaster's former ceo
basically admit it directly to congress
when people hear what ticketmaster
service charge is you know ticketmaster
was set up as a system where they took
the heat for everybody in that service
charge are the credit card fees the
rebates to the buildings rebates
sometimes to artists sometimes rebates
to promoters so ticketmaster has been
that you know we're like the irs we
deliver bad news
yeah it's true ticketmaster is very much
like the irs in that it's an opaque
bureaucracy takes more out of your
paycheck than you think it should and is
represented by men so catastrophically
uncharismatic they look like they're
putting themselves to sleep although it
is worth knowing that while ticketmaster
does share fees with other parties some
of those other parties may also be
ticketmaster because just one year after
that hearing they completed a gigantic
merger with live nation which owns or
operates many of the country's top music
venues and call themselves the largest
producer of live music concerts in the
world and since then they've had
something of a chokehold on live
entertainment in fact the doj recently
alleged that the company had repeatedly
strong-armed venues into using
ticketmaster and retaliated against or
threatened venues that did not use its
services and while life nation denies
that there is no denying just how much
power it has even before that merger
pearl jam at the height of their fame
tried to do a talk without ticketmaster
or their affiliated venues but their
manager admitted at the time they were
going to have to play at weird places
like a ski resort in lake tahoe and a
fairground in san diego and if pearl
cham in the 90s doesn't have the power
to walk away from ticketmaster nobody
does so when you wonder understandably
why can't my favorite artist or magician
just use another ticketing company the
truth is if they want to perform at a
venue that has an exclusive contract
with ticketmaster they actually can't do
that but fees are obviously not the only
complaint that people have with the
ticket buying process another is tickets
disappearing before we have a chance to
buy them concerts for major artists can
sell out so fast sometimes they even
make the news
you know you're hot when you can sell
out madison square garden 20 000 seats
30 seconds that's what justin bieber did
we're talking about two shows at the
garden which seats around 20 000 people
selling out in less time than it takes
me to apply my lip gloss that's crazy
yeah that is crazy not just bieber
selling out 20 000 seats in 30 seconds
though but also that she puts lip gloss
on for over 30 seconds that is just way
too much time i'll show you how you do
it put a timer on the screen right now
check this [ __ ] out
stop the clock look at that
not even close to 30 seconds i didn't
break a sweat and i look
[ __ ] great
and here's the thing
selling 20 000 seats in 30 seconds would
be crazy if that's what bieber did but
he didn't because a report from the new
york ag later revealed fewer than 2 000
tickets were actually put on sale that
day and that's by no means a one-off for
many top shows less than 25 percent of
tickets are initially released to the
general public and in audit of the
blaisdell center in honolulu they found
that when janet jackson played there in
2015 only eight percent of all tickets
went to the general public and when
mariah carey played there the next year
it was just seven percent that was
presumably for her fame to mariah good
[ __ ] luck getting in to see this tour
and if you're wondering where on earth
the rest of the tickets go well they are
deliberately held back to be sold in
other ways and often a big chunk goes to
credit card companies as you might know
from ads like this when lauren broke up
with me she said jack you're a little
boring
boring
boring
[Music]
use any city card to get the benefits of
private pass more concerts more events
more experiences
oh yeah lauren would a boring guy use
our breakup as an excuse to sign up for
a credit card so that i could quietly
stand backstage during an alicia keys
concert and an on-paper sensible
decision i submit that a boring guy
would not do that lauren and i await
your confirmation you're [ __ ] up
lauren
you're [ __ ] up
and it's not it's not just tickets being
siloed away for credit card offers they
can also wind up being put on sale by
the promoter or a radio station or
through an artist's fan club which
sounds fine but a lot of average fans
can't afford special credit cards or
don't have time to jump through hoops in
a fan club but one group very much has
that time and the resources and that is
professional ticket brokers these are
the individuals or companies that buy up
tons of tickets before you can get them
sometimes with the help of bots that
snap them up incredibly quickly because
as you i'm sure assumed all of those
stupid are you a robot tests have very
much not kept them all out because every
time ticket size come up with a new
technology bots find a way around it and
once brokers have those tickets they
will flip them on the secondary market
at a huge markup and at this point we
should probably talk about the secondary
market it's sites like seatgeek
stubhub and surprise surprise
ticketmaster again
these sites badly want you to think of
them as fantu fan marketplaces
ticketmaster even describes its resale
marketplace like this
our objective is if that secondary
market exists we want to create a safe
environment and platform for you to be
able to exchange those tickets you've
bought tickets to go see someone you
love
at the 11th hour your babysitter can't
make it you should have the right to
recoup your costs on that ticket right
because the last thing that you want is
resentment toward your baby to start
festering because of a missed concert
every time you look at their chubby
cheeks you'll just think if you weren't
born i'd have seen the red hot chili
peppers live and i'd have been happier
you're the worst
but the truth is resale sites are not
just fanta fan at all in fact a
government report found that
professional brokers represent either
the majority or the overwhelming
majority of ticket sales on these sites
and they make a lot of money doing it
the new york ag's office found brokers
mark up the price of tickets by an
estimated 49
on average
but sometimes by more than a thousand
percent and in one case by 7 000
that was for a one direction concert by
the way and let me just say i don't
actually regret it it was worth it
my favorite one direction is nile i
don't even know who the other ones are
and i get mad when they sing over the
top of him
and ticket selling sites go out of their
way to cater to their broker clients
because they bring them in a lot of
money for instance while they limit the
number of tickets that any one account
can buy to an event there is an obvious
way for brokers to get around that and
that's simply to have more than one
account this is a practice ticketmaster
has long been aware of there is a ticket
broker conference in vegas each year and
just watch what happened when reporters
went undercover there and talked to
someone at ticketmaster's booth
ticketmaster was busy surrounded by
scalpers i want to know the straight
goods on whether
ticketmaster is going to be policing us
using our multiple accounts
i have a gentleman who's got over 200
ticketmaster.com accounts how many
brokers are using
multiple accounts
actually pretty damn near every one of
them yeah of course they were because
you weren't stopping them although i
will say i'm in absolute awe of anyone
who can remember user names and
passwords for over 200 accounts i just
use one password for all my accounts and
it's niall horan is the best one
direction exclamation mark don't tell
anyone about my perfect password now i
have to tell you ticketmaster insist
that it spends millions on technology to
weed out bad behavior and that that
employees comments were not reflective
of its policies but even taking them at
their word which i am not inclined to do
their whole system is designed to be
opaque especially when it comes to
brokers selling tickets because all the
resale sites including ticketmaster
actively choose to provide anonymity to
them so when you buy a ticket on the
secondary market there is no way to know
the identity of who you're buying from
whether it is a fan whose babysitter
just canceled or a broker who might have
500 other tickets on sale for that same
event which when you think about it is a
bit weird on most sites where people
resell things you can see who you are
buying from take ebay for instance if
you saw this listing for a mickey mouse
shaped potato available for fifty
dollars you could look at the seller see
their username know that they have a 100
favorable rating and feel confident in
your purchase and i already know what
you're thinking you're thinking john you
bought that potato didn't you and it's
under your desk right now no it is not
under my desk
it's over here behold
[Music]
yes
of course we bought it
as you can see it definitely kind of
looks a bit like mickey mouse
the point is
brokers with their identities concealed
can snap up large numbers of tickets and
resell them at a massive markup and
meanwhile the secondary market sites are
themselves making money by charging a
percentage on those ludicrous ticket
prices we found a ticket for adele
selling on seat geek for sixteen hundred
and ninety dollars plus five hundred and
thirty eight dollars in fees and look
here is where we need to deal with an
uncomfortable fact which is the question
of what that ticket is actually worth
because an economist will tell you it is
worth whatever people will pay so if
someone is willing to spend over two
thousand dollars including fees for an
adele ticket that is what it's worth as
gross as that sounds but if adele
doesn't want to charge that there is
going to be a gap between the face value
of the ticket and what someone can get
for it and the whole industry is going
to scramble in to exploit it and
unfortunately live events are uniquely
vulnerable to this because they are
inherently rare bad bunny for instance
is probably only coming to your town
once a year at most and a lot more
people want to see him than there are
seats and while bad bunny could charge
the going rate for every ticket that he
sells he probably doesn't want to do
that because he'd look like an [ __ ]
which he very much isn't he is not a bad
bunny at all despite the name if he's
anything he's a very good bunny
and as long as artists with all good
intentions price their tickets below the
market exploitation is going to happen
and that woman's husband is going to
have to show feet
although it is worth noting some artists
have tried to sneakily get the scalper
price for their tickets without anyone
really noticing remember how justin
bieber was supposedly selling out venues
in seconds while tons of tickets were
held back and another stop on that same
tour reporters looked into some of the
tickets on resale sites and found
something surprising
section 205 row g 14 tickets listed for
246 dollars each and get this ticketing
document showed that entire g row went
to bieber's own tour i think there is no
question when one looks at the document
that bieber is scalping his own tickets
yeah it's true a group of tickets held
for beamer's tour ended up being
released not to the box office but
straight to the secondary market and on
one hand i do get the impulse of if
someone is going to make 246
off that ticket shouldn't it be the
person who is doing the performing but
it still doesn't feel great does it and
it's also not going to stop me from
showing you that clip of him falling
down a hole again
[Applause]
excellent i mean it gets better every
time you see it
and look b was not unique in doing this
a few years back in most that life
nation has helped metallica place
tickets directly onto the resale market
admitting about a dozen other artists
had asked them to do this in recent
years and before you worry no i am not
one of the artists putting tickets to
this show straight onto the resale
market we do it the right way
distributing tickets at random to anyone
who happens to be walking past the
studio at the time half of these idiots
think i'm the warm-up act for drew
barrymore she'll be out any minute folks
she'll be out anymore she's so glad
you're here okay all right
so when you take all of this together
the reason tickets are so hard to get
when they're on sale is that they're
often not on sale and the reason they
cost so much on the secondary market is
that you're paying exorbitant fees to
the platform and might be buying from a
broker or in rare cases even from the
artists themselves and this whole
ecosystem enriches a lot of people who
do not contribute anything to the actual
show that you're paying to see and at
the centre of all of this is
ticketmaster because it turbo charged
many of the shitty practices that have
now become industry standard so what can
we do well congress could inject
transparency into this process by
passing laws that require sites to
disclose their fees upfront along with
the identity of the seller on resale
sites but the truth is much of the power
here is actually in the hands of the
artists because the biggest ones could
do things to tamp down the secondary
market like making their tickets
non-transferable meaning resale is
restricted bands like pearl jam have
experimented with this and before their
2022 was postponed they even worked with
ticketmaster to create an online
marketplace where fans could sell
tickets that they didn't need but with
no additional fees and not for a profit
that seems like the model that everyone
should be using here but if regulators
don't act and artists don't have the
clout or the inclination to require
companies to put those guard rails in
place i'm afraid you as a fan are going
to remain vulnerable to the worst parts
of this system one driven by one of the
most widely loathed companies on the
planet that became even bigger due to a
merger that probably shouldn't even have
been allowed and i know that all of this
may feel a little unsatisfying but if
it's any consolation to you i personally
promise to continue to offer the only
accurately priced entertainment on the
market you know what i'm talking about
i'm talking about one in which tickets
for this show remain available for free
and you can come watch a decaying man
shout numbers apply lip gloss shoddily
and shamelessly earn back your goodwill
by showing your potato that you have to
admit it does look a bit like a famous
mouse